it's funny how you were talking about um
me taking your spot in this podcast
and yeah because i'm literally your
doppelganger i i get that
all the time every single day it feels
so bad for you you got to be [ __ ]
kidding me and i just recently shaved my
mustache too
yeah just recently in quarantine well
you have a ring here
is that yeah yeah you're like you're
going to crawl on my tv
i mean only if you crawl out of my
bathtub
it's so spooky your hair oh grudge yeah
the garage
it's [ __ ] spooky no literally it
connects to my pubes like it's
the same follicle same so when i i'm in
the toilet
peeing it gets to a point where it
crawls down my butt so
if i have to poo i have to put it out i
gotta wrap it up
i might accidentally like because it's
that long i mean
i'm not even like beauty savvy or
anything this isn't on purpose people
are like oh how long did
it take you to grow your hair i'm like i
just don't care me too
it's sheer laziness right anytime i go
actually to i
anytime i actually make it to my hair
salon she's like why why
why is it like this all right you don't
care if i had clippers right now i go
oh if you don't care let me just do it
then would you do it what length
however i want it you don't care you
know why because he will make he will
give you
bald hair and like a shaolin yeah and
then he will put a tiny patch because
he's threatened me before that looks
coming back
that look is definitely coming back dude
i heard from the insiders the hairstyle
insiders
so um is your hair now do you shave down
below
i mean no we could go there i want to go
there yeah let's go there
i'm not asking i'm not asking oh so i'm
screaming
[Laughter]
friendships and pandemic are different
we go straight to it straight to it
yeah you're cooch i i should i shoo the
cooch i shush her first i just shh
[Laughter]
nice quiet quiet on set yeah yeah um
and then i give her the you know
trimmings yeah yeah i made such a
crucial
mistake about two months ago so i got
one of those like hard wax home kits
and i did i did an amazing job with a
front
but i didn't have the heart to ask you
to help me with the tail
yeah so i just blindly put a wad of wax
in my [ __ ]
yeah and i it took me six hours to peel
off chunks
thank god you did that because i have
[ __ ] hair you have a very hairy
[ __ ]
wait you've never seen i have never let
you i've seen your [ __ ]
so [ __ ] it's like chewbacca hairy oh
yeah
that wasn't it that's not your favorite
chewbacca no no no
it was dead yeah listen i'm really great
at impressions
i've seen your [ __ ] before i've been
dating you for eight years you've never
seen my [ __ ] and you know why
why because it's hairy i don't know
i don't i don't spread it no but
check it out okay check it out let's
check it out all right this is what i
have seen all right
sometimes when you're on your stomach
right and i've seen your ass with
underwear
and sometimes you know i goof around and
i put my mouth on it right but that's my
pubes babe that's not my [ __ ] hair
you don't know i will take a picture of
my [ __ ] hair for you and it will make
you cry
well i kind of want to see it now why
would it make her cry
i wonder if there's like a you know
there's wicky feet
wicky anus yeah well it's because it's
not it's like it's not
hairy but it's like like my growth
pattern is very alarming
i don't grow even on my on my fupa
there's not a lot of hair
but on the sides there is it's very in
uneven growth so when you look at my
[ __ ] hair it's like
it's like someone just just recklessly
did
with a razor but didn't really care
through gotcha
it's like a not abundant
not abundant and then also no pattern um
interesting i'm dying to see it i mean
i saw my own [ __ ] in canada why a
different country though
well it's the rule at csx
i was in a okay i was in uh not
vancouver yeah i was in edmonton
wow and they have one of those um hotels
that each
floor is a theme and i don't know why
they keep putting me on the hollywood
themed floor
um
and then when they give you the card i
go thank you and i go to my room um
but one of the rooms has but just all
mirrors uh-huh so i go this is the
perfect
you know opportunity to see my own
[ __ ] because i've never seen it
before what
i mean and how old were you when you
first saw your [ __ ] 42
yeah 42. i recently had this
conversation with a group of girls
and it was just i was the unpopular
opinion of constantly check on your
[ __ ] you
have to i i'm always checking in on her
it's like a house plant you know what i
mean yeah i make sure
she's watered you also got to send it on
the group chats
at least once a month right i do can i
tell you what i saw in my [ __ ]
god damn it in canada yeah in canada
right
it looked like rotten calamari well
listen
it's crusted and wait it's just it was
the tentacles or the rings
yeah which one that's very important
very important detail
the ring
before you die you see the ring i i
actually just often
i send my uh butthole pictures to my mom
just
you know just ask her if it still looks
the same from day one
yeah oh yeah and i'm like you
mom you can count the rings i'm 30. yeah
you know like like a tree like a tree
yeah like a tree
that's how you know i'm going to count
mine tonight
incidentally when you do because i've
you know i've never chopped down a tree
but
i've always i've always wanted to but i
feel like it's not good you know i mean
so